and what really hydrates your skin is
just oil and so if you use a cream
there's more oil in it than lotion i'm
making phd in cosmetic chemist and
there's a lot to unpack here first off
lotions and creams have very similar
ingredients there's about 10 to 20
difference in water both will have
around the same amount of oils as well
you will easily apply 10 or 20 more or
less of a product on different days and
you can actually get lotions with more
oil in them than in creams the real
difference between creams and lotions is
that creams have more solid emulsifiers
like saturated alcohol and that's what
thickens the texture of a cream but
these ingredients are emollients that
smooth skin out they don't tend to be
good occlusive ingredients that seal
water in effectively there's more
similarities than differences between
lotions and creams they aren't like two
completely separate categories it's all
about finding a moisturizer that works
with your skin with a good mix of
occlusives humectants and emollients
whether it's a lotion or a cream